hello everyone and welcome to clash from
the penultimate round of this year's
Super United rapid tournament in Croatia
it is a little island versus Big Island
and it's uh quite quite the game uh
Anand if you didn't know is more than
three times Booker stage bookish is 17
island is 53 so that is absolutely
incredible that Anand can still play
with with these youngsters and
especially at such speed but for those
of you who remember uh they did call
Anand the lightning kid when he was
younger he was the absolute fastest
player alive he uh the the way players
play bullet today online that that's how
fast Anand was on actual over the board
chess if you didn't know so uh that
being said uh let's check it out and
then we are going to discuss the
standings and what happened in the
tournament I was watching all of the
games and I really couldn't decide which
one to show and as the the final two
rounds weren't um uh uh well not much
was happening on the on the top of
boards uh either decide I decided to
show you
um this game even though Island was uh
still still in contention for first
place but that being said let's check it
out so Lucas goes Pawn to E4 and Anand
plays Pawn to C6 he goes for the karokan
defense as he did against Magnus and he
didn't really go his way uh but okay it
was against Magnus he's not gonna
abandon an entire opening just for that
with D4 D5 and here Magnus continue with
that uh exchange variation with Bishop
to D3 but Lucas plays Pawn to F3 he he
goes for the fantasy variation and as as
much as I try I I was never able to
figure out why this is called the
fantasy variation maybe it's like uh
you're out of your mind and you you'd be
living in a fantasy if you if you think
it's actually okay to play F3 here might
be something like that but I don't know
if any of you guys can uh you know uh
figure out an answer to this I would be
very happy if you shared it shared it in
the comments for myself and everyone
else to learn but okay we have Pawn 36
this is the standard reply Knight the C3
with 9 to the D7 and now Bishop to E3
with Bishop to B4 already only a handful
of games in the database with this
position uh Bishop to D3 and now uh Pawn
to C5 with uh e Captain D5 e captures
and D captures in C5 and now there is a
game where Knight G2 F6 was played but
here we have the simple Bishop captures
on C3 and it is now as of move 8 that we
have a completely new game so okay uh
captures now he has tripled pawns but
okay of course you will give at least
one of those back so it's not really
relevant but you have to play like this
if you are to play uh for the win
against the Karo Khan uh Knight the E7
and especially with this fantasy
variation Knight to E2 we have Castles
by both of them and now Queen to C7 a
ready to start collecting on the C file
we have Pawn to A4 now create a
preparing Ponte 5 and Ponte 6 probably
at some point Knight captures and C5
grabbing one of the pawns back and pawn
to A5 with Rook to d8 and and now Bishop
to F4 putting pressure on the queen here
Queen to D7 and now Queen to D2 uh the
C3 Pawn is now nicely defended the Rooks
are connected and you have to figure out
where this Rook is going obviously it's
not very useful on this file probably
the E1 or D1 or maybe even B1 all
depends on what Anand plays so here are
Knight captures and D3 uh it's not I
mean
yeah we always say to take is a mistake
or you shouldn't capture something just
uh you know for for the sake of
capturing something but it's hard for
Ireland to develop your Rook is still
undefended the Rooks are not connected
so you can't play B6 to play something
like Bishop to B7 you can't develop your
bishop and uh well you're just not uh in
control of of that much space so I don't
decides the capture on D3 this un
doubles uh Gooker spawns and now goes
Knight to C6 now he will move the queen
play F6 Queen to F7 and then get the
bishop into the game and that's how he
will connect his Rook said okay Knight
to G3 we have F6 and now uh Rook after
E1 this is an open file so The Rook will
be much more useful than in this final
Queen to F7 and now Queen to F2 with
Bishop to E6 and now Bishop to E3 uh
putting pressure on that A7 Pawn so you
have to be careful how you develop Queen
back to D7 and now Knight D2 now Google
said all right the bishop here has been
weakened by the playing against six now
we're gonna bring our Knight over to F4
to put pressure on the center end on
that Bishop so Bishop to F5 attacks the
D3 pawn and uh interestingly Google
still plays uh Knights therefore and now
what's the idea behind this can G5 be
played you just kick away the Knight and
pick up the D3 Pawn uh it could it can
very well be played the problem is now
once uh the Knight moves and of course
you could play some like Knight stage
five then you you pressure this Pawn but
even if you don't go for this even if
play some like Knight st2 and you will
capture the pawn mid this looks like uh
too much weakening of the position just
for the price of one form but probably
Knight the H5 would be played then you
have to defend then G4 is played and uh
okay it's a very much a double-edged
game but it's not it's not a mistake or
anything Aaron decides to go for Queen
to F7 instead and now Pawn to H4 now the
pawn is coming to H5 uh the Knight
nicely defends it and of course you
already uh stopped the pawn to G5
so upon the age six point the H5 and now
Knight to E5 putting more pressure on
the D3 pawn and uh and uh just defends
it Rook eater D1 it's always hard to
decide whether to play Rook a to D1 or
rookie to D1 I feel like even in 2023 uh
even the engine still have no idea which
Rook belongs uh to The crucial Square uh
because I think the the answer lies uh
somewhere somewhere far far away where
the computer still cannot um decide and
a human would actually decide on this
better but who knows Rook eat the D1 we
have Knight back to C6 and now Rook D to
B1 now going uh after that B7 Pawn Rook
to D7 adding more defense Here and Now
Rook to B5 okay uh you are putting some
pressure on this Pawn but really you are
threatening C4 as the bishop on F5 is
undefended so here A6 trying to chase
The Rook Bank Rook to C5 and now Rook
the E8 we have pawned the C4
uh this cannot be played as the bishop
on F5 is undefended and uh Anand plays
Pawn to D4 now here you could just
decide to trade everything well it's an
id5 uh you put pressure on the D3 Pawn
let's say D4 now Knight comes here
attacks the rook and the queen uh Knight
captures and E3 Bishop capture C
captures on D5 and now Rook captures on
D5 and okay everything uh gets traded
off uh not not a bad position probably
even on this better but he decides to
play D4 right away uh and okay now it
would be too dangerous because uh this
would create too strong of a pass Pawn
so Bishop back to D2 and now Rook the E5
countering the rook and C5 uh Rook to D5
and now Rook e captures on D5 C counters
on D5 and now the idea is uh of course
uh uh what if Anan plays The Rook
characters on D5 well that's exactly
what he should do you should give up
this exchange probably you will uh win
the D3 Pawn as well and you will
definitely have compensation however
after C capture Sunday five nights the
E7 was played and now comes spawn to G4
and all of a sudden anand's pieces are
running out of squares this bishop now
only has the H7 Square so that's exactly
what I'm in place and now not Queen
captures on D4 the movie are probably
all looking at a rook to C1 the idea
being of course that now if Knight
captures and D5 then Rook the C8 check
and Anand resides there is no way to
uh Save the King as the bishop is on H7
you can just start giving up pieces and
that's it so instead after G5 after this
I wrote the C1 move uh G5 is played but
now H captures uh on G6 here instead of
G5 a stubborn defense was very much
needed something like King to eight
shade but uh you know then okay you you
have this you can put the King on H7
decided for Pawn to G5 and this is
giving Lucas a bit too much he plays H
captures and G6 Alpha saw Bishop
captures and now Queen to H4 putting
pressure on the H6 pawn pawn to H5 even
King th7 still might be a little bit
better but uh still it's a very very bad
forum and H5 was played G captures an H5
and now pawn bishop to F5 opening up the
G file but uh it's opening it for white
as you can see King to F2 Now The Rook
can also come to G1 now Knight captures
on D5 okay King to H7 still maybe a
little bit better but white is still
winning Knight captures on D5 was played
now comes Rook to see it with check King
to H7 and now there is only one winning
move for Lucas but uh yeah not that
difficult to spot so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for gookish
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this uh
weird idea and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is night the
G6 this is what gookish played and he
was in this position on move 40 that
Anand resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here they even
had plenty of time I think they had like
six minutes and four minutes uh but uh
you know there's no reason to continue
this and of course Anand knows it Rook
to h8 is coming and even I if you stop
this let's say okay you can capture but
then it's a double check you would have
to capture here and then Rook to h8 and
there's no defense like Queen to H5 is
coming queen to H6 this is uh game over
and if you try something else instead of
Bishop captures and G6 you could try
moving the king but now look at this
beauty Knight the E5 Forks the queen and
the rook and that's pretty much it you
either resigned here or you take the
Knight and then Queen G5 as the pawn is
now gone from defending the G5 Square
Queen a king H uh seven and then Queen
to H6 will be Checkmate as I'm sure you
have forgotten about our good friend the
bishop on D2 guarding the H6 Square so
those are only some of the reasons why
Anand resigned but yeah 40 moves a
beautiful win uh uh by
Gucci and this is what happened in the
final rounds even though Magnus had a
really bad second day he had a pretty
great uh last day and he almost caught
up the leaders Fabiano Corona and diani
ponishi who took a shared lead after
three days or rather after nine rounds
of the rapid tournament in Zagreb uh
Magnus played the last game against
lupolescu Constantin who really did not
have a great tournament and he even
played a terrible terrible line of the
king's Indian defense and uh well he he
gave Constantin everything that he could
do dream of but it just wasn't enough at
some point he equalized and then just
pushed for a win as he was much much
better on time and the Fabi and nepo
both won their first game or rather they
won their around seven game and then
just drew the remainder of the games at
to retain first place so there we have
it Fabian Nepal leading the Rapids of
course it will be continued through the
blitz tomorrow we have two days of Blitz
and then the points will be accumulated
Magnus in third with 11 then on and then
uh both with 10 uh Heron and won this
game instead of lost uh he would also be
on 12 but what are you gonna do uh
and uh and a rapport online six also
definitely not his tournament he can do
much better than this uh and
Constantinople with two points in last
place uh so yeah that's this uh short
coverage of the super United rapper
tournament in Croatia like I said we're
continuing with two days of Blitz so
stay tuned for that uh I'm probably
gonna cover two two two the two or more
games per day but who knows I might
cover less I might cover more you know
you can never really really tell with
these uh things uh so yeah once again
really hope you enjoyed it very nicely
done by
Gucci here but Lucas just punished his
uh uh G5 breakthrough uh here like I
said here King Day and the game
still goes on but you know it's uh it's
always hard to decide to go for a
stubborn defense this looks more so you
just play it and hope for the best
that's what Anand did and that's what
led to his downfall so yeah once again
really hope you enjoyed it I would like
to thank James Eugene Cashman John
Austin and not completes the Paul Miller
and Brad Roth for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful tournament only in the blitz
section checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day